-Welcome to "Late Night"
everybody.
I hope you all had a good
weekend.
My wife and I got nostalgic fo
the good ol' days,
so we watched "Tiger King" and
made some sourdough.
Simpler times.
Let's get to the news.
According to a new report
published
in the "New York Times,
White House aides asked th
governor of South Dakota
about the process of addin
additional presidents
to Mount Rushmore.
As for when they asked, I'
guessing right after
they hung up with the governor
of North Dakota.
Sorry, wrong number.
Sorry.
You guys, there are two Dakotas.
I don't know where the other one
is.
Get an atlas, Dan.
President Trump told a crowd i
Ohio last week
that former Vice President
Joe Biden wants to
"take away your guns, destro
your second amendment,
no religion, no anything, hurt
the bible, hurt God."
Man, he is grasping for answer
like your aunt during
Pictionary.
No, really,
just no bible, hurt God.
Aunt Carol, it was surfboard
The word was surfboard.
After President Trump signed a
executive order over the weekend
that requires $400 in extr
unemployment benefits,
Republican senator Ben Sasse
called it
"unconstitutional slop."
Ew, you just got "Sassed."
Better watch it, Mr. President
you would not like him when he's
angry...
or when he's happy
or anytime really.
You see, the problem is yo
don't really like people,
and he's not that likable.
Infectious disease expert,
Dr. Anthony Fauci said
in an interview last week that
he and his family
have had a security detail since
April after being harassed
and receiving death threats over
his role
in the coronavirus response.
And also, that he has a pretty
good idea who, "President X" is.
According to a new report, the
record -- a record number
of people have given up thei
U.S. citizenship this year
It's kinda like when we al
threw out
our Blockbuster video card
It was a good idea for a while
and then suddenly, it was just
very clear
they were going out of business.
NASA announced last week that it
will no longer refer to planet
and galaxies by offensive
nicknames.
That's right, Uranus will no
just be called "your butthole.
Ally Hord for the win.
According to a new report,
psychics and fortune tellers
in New York City have seen a
large uptick in business
amid the coronavirus, so i
you're willingly letting
someone read your palm right
now, I too can tell you
what your future looks
like.
Cheetos has released a new lin
of mac and cheese products
so now Fauci's doing daily
briefings on that, too.
You know, it's too early to tell
how delicious it is,
but we'll try.
I do think it would be good with
hydroxychloroquine.
103-year-old woman in Michigan
got a tattoo last week
to check it off her bucket list.
Well, I just hope she doesn'
regret it when she gets older.
And finally, a jewelry company
in Israel said recently
they're making a gold
diamond-encrusted face mas
that will be the most expensiv
face covering in the world
worth $1.5 million.
And, oh, my God,
you're wearing it wrong.
That was the monologue.